Tại buổi học báo phó chụt tệ quyết bán như sân tình,
quyển phân tông và thất sở ngành lên quan,
đã tông tin tự các cơ quan báo gí về công tắc tự hộ cửa nạn.
Vềm điều tra phụ việc công tắc khổ sợ những người bị đương và ra định tất cả nạn nhan tự vòng.
Chào đỏ vào râu dơ chiều ngày mùi xin thống bài,
trên đẹp bà tình dễ ra tình trọng thời tiết sống lúc hết sức phức tạp.
Sân tình sự cố tay nạn dùi sông nghiêm trọng trên việc hạc lông,
lâm tổ vệng xanh nằm bị tảm,
bình kìm sốt quyền ở bài mô không năm,
đang trong quá trình sở phát thông quan việc hạc lông,
đã bị lật uống, giấc đến tiết hạc nạn này vình gười.
Thì nạn được tông tin, đúng ở năng phút sào lực lượng trước năng của tình đã có mắt tảyển sường,
đồng tỏi huy động tổng lực phương tệ nhất lực thông sàng cửa không nào.
Vào ngày xong tỏa đi, chúng ta chỉ là ở biệt đáng điều ngày xong mè đặcu,
tổ vinh thần đã có mặt ở chiến thiệt sường.
Đồng trời máo cáo của anh,
ở đây đào tình, đào các chiến thông trở,
tổ vinh thần, tổ vinh thần, tổ vinh thần, tổ vinh thần,
tổ vinh thần, tổ vinh thần, tổ vinh thần.
Cái cây không kiện lồi tảo huy động,
bước cao nhận để ra pột cao như tổ.
Khi định gần của phần, không sự biệt phần,
chứng rồi năng, công ngán tình,
bột đánh của một thải quân,
để rồi ra, bột đánh của các thân định và kính đánh.
một chăm mừng chăm tồng rùn định trên với thà lòng,
vũn tà là đáng, đáng đáng đạc và có chức lượng và ăn toàn kỹ thuật là cao hơn kêu phạc.
Ví dụ, như người kai tàu vị trang thì có nhé hệ số ăn toàn về một nịch.
Thì là hai thì qua, vào cao của ghi đây trong khi là tư trợn của đáng kéo,
vì là trên một cái hệ số thì nào đã đạc rồi.
Nhưng mà cái to lệ là đạc, như kêu thịt của trợn về ăn toàn.
Hệ số ăn toàn được lịch, hai cái bà.
Hệ này bởi người đã được cứu xấu mong mong mong người thịt mạng.
Công tốc bàn sau thịt thệ các nạn nhân cho xa đình, đang được khoảng tất.
Nào bào chú đảo về mặt nhân đạo.
Tình cũng đang tiếp tục quan tâm, đổ lực cao nhất,
để tìm kiếm các nạn nhân còn nất tiết.
Công có tình đang, có tiếp tục.
Ởa, với các nạn nhân chứ đang tắt nhad,
của y động của ra lửa phụ nhận,
với tình thần hành trường nhất, rất cực nhất,
để bộn chức tìm kiếm dọc,
và để tìm những số lãn nhân của nất tiết.
Và đừng phơi, cũng tôi đang chỉ đạo,
kêu quan kể xếm được trà, có tìm.
Tộc trông, hành trường điều tra lãm gióng mình nhân của việc đẻ xử lý,
trong nống quy phố lọc.
Phó chú tịch quy bán như xa tình,
vệ phần công nhận mạng,
của ạc tình hát sức xếm đổi đau,
đổi mất mắt với xa đình những người gặp nạn,
cho phụ nắm tổ su lịch trên việc hạ lâu.
Hoa viên tìm kiếm những nạn nhân còn lại,
tình cũng đã hộ xe ở tối đa,
cho những người gặp nạn.
Đông thời huy động các buồn sảo hội hoa để tích tục hộ xe,
đặc biệt tình cũng định hướng sẽ nhận đổi đau nhiều chẻ mô côi,
bởi vụ nắm tổ này.
Đông chỉ đàn nghị các cơ quan bảo xí tích tục xếm xe nông hành công tình,
cho gọi xin phát xím tổ xanh tổ đổi.